歡迎收看最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李肇華
今天大盤看起來溫溫的指數
沒有什麼中場之長了46點
似乎是一個有點小小平淡的盤
但是如果細看到類股跟個股
就會發現
其實有很多AI相關的領頭羊
在默默的創下歷史新高
例如說像今天看到川湖
哇 漲停創高之外
創意也創高
臺光店也創高
像這樣子的一個現象
其實也默默的暗示著我們
牌股在AI相關的領軍之下
以及有人先表態
儘管指數盤整
但肋骨上面是很值得做留意的
而骨的部分呢
我們也看到
像回答微軟
我們之前都說
科技七巨頭
好像有點暗然十四
但現在也都接近前高的位置
還有美股有些新創的 AI 概念股
獲利成基單 叫出來也是往上提升的
在強勁的基本面之下
我們遇到台股現在指數的整理不要擔心
達人們來賓們要幫您挑出
向現階段選股最好的方向來歡迎他們
第一位是股市施工 永蓮老師
施工今天要來鐵口直段
就是台股可能打第二隻腳的機會
有點渺茫
也許是一盤帶疊
也許是整理過後
就要直接往上衝了
當然大哥台積電要過前高
剛剛講了
已經有非常多的 AI 領頭羊帶頭創高了
以及每股的巨頭們
也都在前高的附近
等一下來幫您掃一遍
除了上週
施工獎的股票非常強勢之外
這週我們就要看到
所謂的一線 AI 權值股
誰是下一個表態創高的領頭羊
第二位是我們的題材獵人漢偉哥
漢偉哥最喜歡的機器人
今天在排名上也是非常厲害喔
索羅門連續性的創下破斷高
盟力創下歷史新高
難道都只是因為
這個禮拜開始所謂的自動化大展嗎
不是這樣
有可能是一個接棒的態勢
因為今天光學概念股也是有非常多
漲停表態的
等一下告訴你
整體機器人的布局該怎麼看
另外有注意到嗎
貨櫃航運
因為運價連續三周往上漲
今天萬海爺漲停
到底貨櫃航運爭一波
有沒有可能複製之前
連續性的漲勢呢
等一下教您觀察的指標
以及資產如何做平均的分配
第三位是我們的冠軍擦盤手
雲翔哥
雲翔哥一直在注意回答的動向
電力的地圖現在擴散
台股不只光寶科創高了
相關的像公立元件
今天的狀況很好
碳化性等等跟電力有關的
今天也都有表現
等一下看高座地交凝挑
還有光通訊
雖然我們常常講
他們現在的營收狀況撐次不齊
可是有一個事情確定
零化音
零化音真的是有夠缺
所以等一下在零化音概念
不是都漲停嗎
還能看高座地嗎
有的雲翔哥幫你找囉
好 首先有請永年老師
好
永年老師
這個這句話其實有點敏感
因為大家都在等
有沒有可能再回來一下
讓我買
其實事情就是這樣
回得很深的時候不敢買
然後不回了就好想買
好想他打自己的腳
好希望你趕快來
不過沒有關係
你現在看台積
因為輝達微軟都在占前高了
所以這一波老AI
還有誰有可能輪到也要占前高
那可多了
可多了
沒錯
我們先看一下
我今天給大家看的是
除了OpenAI
他們準備要掛牌
對不對
AnchorPick
他們可能要掛牌
OK 好
掛牌對整個AI產業有什麼影響
另外我給大家看
輝達跟維軟的走勢
一個是日線圖
一個是周線圖
我要講走勢的原因是這樣子
大家注意看
輝達的股價
在5月14號就見到高點
我們台灣的加權指數
我們不要講台灣加權指數
或者是包括美國股市
他們什麼時候見高點
在6月下旬才建高點
對不對
然後7月才開始正式的跌
所以你看
他們就比較早就見到這樣
然後他其實在6月29號
就已經打下左腳了
就他波段的跌幅
就跌室在6月29號就結束了
那表示怎麼樣
表示當初這一些賣揮達
賣微軟的這些資金
他們先跑掉了
然後把這資金轉到別的
別的這個產品裡面去
別的產業裡面去
然後等到大家都開始跌得很慘的時候
這些資金又轉回來
這個AI的概念股裡面去了
像是輝達 像是微軟
都是這個樣子 都是這個樣子
尤其是你看一下
像是微軟來講的話
為什麼轉微軟呢
因為其實真正跟我們台灣
真的有關係的還是CSP
是
那所以呢我們看一下
像微軟的話
這是周獻土
這邊做了一個M頭
他跌下來跌得很慘
這邊做了一個更大的一個WD
你知道嗎
股市真的好證人
對
所以當初大家賣他們的時候
都在講什麼
就說資本租金太高啦
那營收跟營民是不能cover住啦
頭部成型了
對 頭部成型啦對不對
現在底部成型了
現在他就好不得了 對不對
這其實好不好
都是看資金流去哪裡了
那我們是認為說
現在的資金竟然非常明顯的
流回了AI概念股的話
那當然我們現在的以後
這一段時間要注意的股票
就是AI概念股了
好 AI概念股的話
就是台股主力不對啊
對 沒有錯
不過大家也會想說
漲到這邊
不是已經有一些股票也預壓力
然後遇到關鍵均線了
那到底要不要回檔一咪咪
給我們一種心理上
我好像可以再來做逢地承接
OK 好 回檔一點
那當然是可以接受的
你說要回檔到原來的低點
就是再跌破是4萬點
那是一定出事了
才會跌到4萬點附近
因為他現在如果跌到月線
月線目前才4萬4千點
就沒有 跌到月線
其實都算合理
都算合理的 OK
那為什麼到這邊
到4萬6千出頭就上不去了呢
這個很重要的大家注意看
當初在4萬6千500點
到4萬8千2百18點
這個區間裡面
他的日均量是多少呢
大概是在1.6兆到1.7兆之間
那麼這麼大的量
你現在用了
這個才什麼不到1兆的量
想要突破確實有困難
我覺得有困難
除非怎麼樣
除非台積電發動
否則的話是有困難的
那有沒有機會呢
那我們現在要看
為什麼我說他不太可能
會打回來四萬點
來 我給大家看一下
足跡數預估今年的GDP是多少
準備衝11.05
11.05是什麼意思
我還很年輕的時候
那個是我來看過
自從中年以後
就沒有再看過了
那是多久以前
39年前
所以
所以39年前有這個
雙位數的成長率過這樣子
所以那個時候叫台灣奇蹟
OK
台灣奇蹟就那個時候創下了
OK 好
那另外呢
7月份上市上櫃總營收
而是5.79兆
那這個年增率本來是47.5
這很恐怖
沒有錯
非常恐怖的一個數字
然後第三個呢
台幣最近強生了
8月終於看到外資明顯的回頭買超
沒錯
回頭買超
買超有多少
連今天的加上去
大概差不多有2700億了
這個數量其實還蠻驚人的
OK
所以外資已經回頭買了
那第三最後一個呢
就是上個禮拜MCI調升我們的全中
全中三升
那這些被動型的這個ETF外資
他是不是要回過頭來
要買股票
月底對不對
沒有錯 在8月31號之前一定要買
那當然啦
還有一點點的小問題是什麼
就是禮拜三台紙期要結算
是
那結算的話
到今天為止
外資手上還有8.3萬口的這個進空單
對 雖然在過去五天
已經回補了5000口了
那還有8.3萬口
那明天後
尤其是明天
賣牙可能會比較中電
這個大家可能要稍微的注意一下
可是我還是覺得拉回
應該要找買一點
好 因為有點一下
我們第三位有雲香哥嗎
他他能不能一己之力
買選擇權的空單
對
對抗外資的三八萬
三千口結算
沒錯 小Case
對他來講 那小事情
台灣全靠他
好 所以現在如果說
我們的日均量能夠達到1.2到1.3兆的話
那是有機會來突破4萬8000 2百18000
是有機會
那可是要挑戰5萬點
那還是要看台積電啦
是
對
就是我們剛剛講要看台積電
好
他還沒過高
他的高在2535
不太沒有過高
他這一波反彈才反彈幾%
你知道嗎 12%
但是他畢竟在所有均線之上
對
OK 才反彈12%
真的我覺得很冤枉了
OK 好
那如果我們用周線來看的話
你會發現呢
他在這邊
他的正當的幅度越來越小
有一點收斂三角形的這種味道
越盤越小 越盤越小
那這個禮拜呢
他如果一直維持在這樣子的走勢的話
我覺得他有機會
下禮 最慢下禮拜有機會要開始上來
要表態 對
表態
那麼我們看一下
他預估呢
今年的EPS大概是112塊
因為又上調了
好像又增加了一些些
本來是差不多110
111塊
我是稍微把它調高到112塊
馬上發現了
對 真是
真的不能騙你
好 對
那預估北京一比呢
大概21.5倍
然後我們之前講過了
外資給他的
給台積電的買點是多少
北京一比是20倍
對
最近有稍微調降一些
那目標也有稍微降低一點
不過都沒有差
因為我們現在要看誰
我們現在看的是明年的EPS
已經進入到那個8月下旬了
對 要看明年的預估
那個外資評估平均的EPS
大概看143塊
好 那143塊呢
我們用今天的收藩價
2400數143呢
預估的本益比才16.8倍
拜託好不好
16.8倍有沒有覺得很委屈啊
對不對 太委屈了
為什麼很委屈呢
來看一下
剛才我講了 外資給予
這個台積電的買點
是20倍的本益比
對不對 所以我們用143
乘以20倍
我們不要說它的目標是多少
就是呢 買點 基本買點
2860塊
所以呢 理論上來講
今年在這個封關之前呢
應該可以看到這個價位
那如果看到這個價位的話
換算成加權指數呢
可以漲到五萬四千六百點
好 突然間不是五萬點的事情
是五萬五千點的事情
沒有錯
不過 台電目前是把空間
都先讓給各族群來表態喔
對 沒錯
這個就是大哥的風範
你知道嗎 對不對
讓這個小弟先去吃香喝辣的
大哥在後面墊後
OK 吃更好
我們看這張表就知道了
創新高的公司
很多都是產業族群裡面的
大公司 龍頭
對 龍頭之類的
然後其實都跟AI有關係
然後其實他們大部分
都潛藏了一段時間
然後這一次反彈呢
不囉嗦直接的紛紛創新高
既然他們這些公司
都有辦法創新高的話
這黃色的
都是有創
這一波都有創立指新高的
川普也是這個AI奇蹟了
創意今天創新高
台光電今天創新高
維吟超過他的股號
今天一度有超過6669
華碩上禮拜
對 上禮拜
然後光寶可今天
都創新高
那就表示怎麼樣
既然這些老的
老牌的AI概念股
都開始創新高的話
那是不是表示整個AI概念股的族群
都有機會在創
尤其是剛才我們講的台積電
我覺得真的是進可攻退可守的股票
你看一下創意這一波
這波真的是
7月27號施工有特別講到
創意打到半年線已經有點超跌了
其實因為他股性靈活
這邊還有在多跌的一些
多跌的一段
真的叫V轉
他這個是標準的大V轉
對 沒錯
這個好像那個當初呢
在鄉下看到那個貴族
貴族長大的時候
貴族損
三天大概就長那麼高
是吧
那劍鼎也是一樣
劍鼎的反彈氣勢也差不多
連續兩根漲停
是 然後金居也是
金居他的表現比較溫吞一點
可是我覺得他還沒有走完
還沒有走完
還可以繼續觀察下去
好 那我們就看
最近的漲幅比較沒有那麼大的
就廣達
那廣達來講的話
其實你看他第二季的
單季的營收 毛利
跟營業利率跟EPS
都創了歷史新高
技術面向來講
這邊是左肩
這邊是底
現在這邊在做右肩
頭肩底的一個組織
那他現在唯一欠缺的成交量
稍微出一點量的話
就有機會
這個來挑戰原來的企業點
因為剛剛施工
其實有兩檔股票
見頂跟金居
後來量都已經有放出來
對 沒錯
所以廣達就是等這個量
就是等量
ok 他現在那盤也是合理的
他這邊稍微在半年線
這邊震盪盤等一下
然後來挑戰季線
我覺得是合理的一個走勢
好 那再來一個剛剛光寶科
光寶科呢
他今天的最領人注目是什麼
一早就衝到286.5
創地史新高了
然後就掉下來
兔頭齋就下了
收在盤中的最低點 263.5
那看起來真的滿恐怖的
對不對
可是你看它成交量
立刻縮 沒有放大
立刻縮小
而且它的大量是在這裡
大量在這邊
所以我個人是認為說
它只要能夠守住十日線
守住十日線
它應該還有更高點
可以值得期待的
最後一個是解答題
因為我們剛剛看到那張表上面
就是有一個綠塊塊
自己加
可是前面是強勢的
為什麼今天突然去一根疊停產
那麼兇汗
對 它比較麻煩是今天這個量有增加
量有增加
那這個是比較麻煩一點
可是呢
它的問題在哪裡
它會問你當然第一個是要有發現
憲針
要發現憲針
那可能會稀釋它的股本
那所以呢
這個是大家比較擔心的
另外還有一個
真正這個會讓大家去賣它的原因是
第二劑的毛利率呢
是9.62%
那9.62%還好吧
比以前的毛三倒數好多了
可是他比上一季12.01%
大幅度的下滑
這個差距太大了
所以會造成大家心裡的不安
不安定感
可是我要跟大家講的是什麼
因為他們做這個AI伺服器
本來毛利率就不會高
為什麼
尤其是在過去這半年
哇 這些林主卿的股票
這個價格大漲 對不對
那漲得這麼多
他就成本拉高了
所以它毛利率一定下降
可是問題在哪裡
問題在這邊
你的這個AI的伺服器
他們的單價是很高的
所以你毛利率雖然低了
可是因為你的營收大幅度增加
它足夠cover掉你的毛利率的下降
所以你可以看
它上半年的EPS是17.73元
年幅率92.7%
對不對
毛利率雖然下滑了
可是你這個真正的營收
實質的EPS還是有大部份增加
將近一倍
所以我是覺得說
929只過一段時間
大家就可以忘記這件事情了
那8月份的外資
尤其是8月份的外資
連續買超過3.8萬張
所以外資還是持續看好這張股票
所以我覺得它大概可能要整理
大概四天到一個禮拜左右
然後看大盤
如果大盤能繼續往上走的話
這支股票應該還是有高點可以值得期待
對 現在真的是決戰毛利率
因為看廣達
如果跟去年同期比
其實是比較衰退
可是跟上一季比
好像度過了那個低潮期了
對
可是季家卻是在第二季
卻明顯的遇到了一個相對的瓶頸
所以決戰第三季
第三季大家的毛利率
可能都要有
就差不多了
對 要回溫的一個狀況
克服了所謂的學習曲線
沒有錯 沒有錯
希望這些老AIM們加油了
謝謝
好這邊非常謝謝施工
永年老師
謝謝
好 施工上禮拜
或者是在股災期間
講的很多股票都往上衝
甚至還帶量
但是漲到46000點了
我們就要期待有更多的
全職移憲兵來做加持
剛剛有提到雖然像今天
技嘉區的一根跌停板
但是決戰第三季
當第二季毛利率能夠維穩的公司
現在市場上都會給予比較好的評價
小兒到第三季 克服零組件的漲價缺掉等等的問題
第四季 機櫃又大量出貨的話
這些AI股就有機會再創高峰
尤其是台積電將帶領台股
繼續往五萬點以上做賣金
好 廣告回來 題材獵人
浩偉哥要來跟大家分享了
大家覺得這一次的自動化展覽
是機器人長的主因嗎
會不會是執掌的展覽呢
浩偉哥那麼長期的觀察機器人會告訴您
真的不是
因為族群一樣有人在創高
而且接下來大戶以及他們的基本面
都在改善中
還記得應該是兩年前
因為背板股的帶動機器人
著實有一波大的漲幅
當時的指標股叫做索羅門
成前了兩年多
索羅門又來了
這是不是有指標式的意義呢
因為上個禮拜剛好
我們也有來賓聊到索羅門
我就還想說
兩年沒有動的公司
都大區間而已
結果他現在不是
他抽了一個波段很高
還有今天大立光 玉京光
漲停板
他們都是屬於比較多題材的
執掌展覽嗎
還是展覽後
有他的更多利多
另外貨櫃航運
謝謝這個航海王
浩宇哥有來幫我們講
因為你已經連續三周長
這個上海集裝箱指數了
但是到底延續性
如何怎麼判斷
我覺得這個機械
應該慢慢有業績
然後航運股應該慢慢會有資金進來
所以我們大戰 多半
應該不會太晚
我覺得大概這禮拜
應該這兩個族群都有機會發動
那首先大家看這禮拜的重頭戲
就是台灣的機器人跟智慧化
自動化展
大概在禮拜三到這禮拜登場
那接下來還有北京的世界機器人大會
第二屆世界人型機器人運動會
都密集在8月份的下旬開始展開
那我覺得大家目前在入股關注的焦點是
語速的 IPO 8月份
對已經開始募集了嘛
那募集到了這個上市價格是150塊
這個未上市按盤交易
已經來到520塊了
按盤交易
對黃牛票嘛
你買不到就透過這種按盤
去跟那種有深構到的人去做一個交易
這價格520塊
代表說他在8月底之前掛牌
如果以這個價格開出來的話
他的市值會衝得非常前面
那全球機械的股票
就有一個指標性的意義存在
那這個是講說題材面的部分
那這是業績面的部分
因為上個禮拜五
LG跟輝達宣布要合作
合作的重點在哪
他大概在明年的第一季要推出
LG的雙足機器人
對 用這個輝達接身手
機器人大腦
所以也就代表說
其實在明年你會看到
韓國的LG開始推人型機器人
所以業績在明年應該說
在今年第四季會有一個
比較明顯的拉貨槽
今天機器人我覺得算是蠻熱鬧的
因為索羅門掌庭班嘛
那他的特定是在於說
他今年上班機專的4.55元
那去年為什麼索羅門好像談話一切
就因為早上去之後業績沒有跟上來
大家覺得機器人講得很美好
但是營收啊貨幣都沒有出來
他上班機專4.55
真的以前想要索羅門就是沒有什麼賺錢啊
在賺到4.55已經算真的不錯耶
所以代表說其實在機器人的部分
我們都可以看到業績明顯在這邊
整體上來看都出現年增的成長
那接下來看到今天很整齊另外的是這個光學鏡頭
光學 因為這個光學就很廣了
對不對 有機器人啦
甚至最近的無人機啦
甚至光通訊啦
全部都跟這有關還有 iPhone
對 還有手機
所以我覺得這代表今天其實盤面上
雖然說盤有點無聊
但這樣的主題開始冒出頭來了
那我們來看一下相關的線型
那當然首先還是幫大家關心一下機體
怎麼那麼快 忽然切進機體
不過這邊的話關心一下是因為
今天有很多機體也是開高走低殺尾盤啦
所以藉由發獎狀
先在這邊先見眼基底
後面就繼續講機器人
對 因為這兩黨是沒問題的模範生
股價都非常強
預創去創了26年新高
那留意到預創明天是出關
所以你要看出關有沒有出關的賣
畢竟短相來看長那麼多
所以出關如果爆大量黑K棒的話
你可能就是稍微不要追高
那當然因為他還沒有公佈七月份字節
應該也會非常好
所以我覺得可能就是
有拉回 縫回做一個買信的動作
還OK
因為目前法人是在買方的
投信跑進來買好猛
8月3號還有一個講長了70%
很難跟耶
那萊亞科這種大牛應該好一點吧
對 萊亞科我覺得是籌碼好
你看土羊在那買方
那目前現金他還是沿著五線貓墊高
那萊亞科我覺得觀察是什麼
因為今天韓國股市修市
所以明天的三星海利市
那今天晚上美光
我看盤錢大概長了3%
所以如果說今天晚上
美股跟日韓股市的記憶體續長的話
那顆它指標一是
它542如果續創新高
對於整個記憶體的一個指標一都還在
那只是說大家覺得
滑房店今天開到走低
還有旺紅一直很弱
對 利息點出現重挫
我覺得現在看起來
其實台灣族群都有這樣的情況
就是台股量能9000多億嘛
所以這種大股本的公司
就很難出現整齊性的上漲
那我們只是說
有龍頭股先創高的話
其他股票就先等補漲就好了
那另外大家也關心群聯
哇 利息是那麼好
反而股價不漲
118塊的單季EPS
那我覺得如果群聯的話
可能就要耐心等一下
因為現在是法人不看好他
但我覺得他公司的業績還是非常好
所以目前我們可以看到
像日本的凱瑄、Sendysk
相關Netflix的股票其實慢慢轉強
就看一下那些所謂國際指標大廠
股價如果又往上轉強創高的話
能不能對台灣的模組廠
有一定的推薦的作用
好 因為有南海科代頭
我想上有不用太煩惱
模組廠可能就要等法人的認同了
因為群聯法說會後
法人的認同度比較低
謝謝啦
那我們來看一下
就是機器人的部分
好回到機器人
索羅門因為之前每次看他
就覺得不會動啊
可是這一波的掌勢
長得不一樣了
對所以你如果以這個
現行來看的話
他其實整理非常久一段時間
那當然我們在遇到股災的時候
7月份台股在破底的時候
他反而是沒有什麼跌到
那代表他籌碼
我覺得沉澱的夠乾淨
那今天一段我覺得
瞎真是所謂的一個
展覽的利多題材
股價175塊
我記得他之前的例子新高是187塊
對
所以代表他如果在近期
這禮拜能夠創造例子新高的話
相關的AI視覺股票
就會有一些領頭羊的一個帶動作用
那索文門因為他是具備指標的意義
他如果創高的話
大家覺得機線會來真的
復股風
對
那索文門當然大家會覺得是比較偏向
那種所謂的活潑的股票
那我們講文件股票就看上癮
那上癮這一波上癮
我覺得特性在哪
他股價其實打到半年線之後
開始有點B型翻到往上
那現在的月線季線要黃信交叉了
你可以看到上影
最近的外資 投信
大戶都在買方
那所謂我們純粹是大戶大買
是
所以我覺得他可能
這個禮拜就應該有機會做一個表態的動作
目前我覺得最央囊股票看起來
都具備他的指標意義
他如果最央囊股票同步再往上走高的話
可能機器人的一個掌勢會更加延續
因為今天盟力已經先偷跑
是
對 他已經先創立新高了
但尾盤壓回來
我覺得有點跑太快
所以回來等他一下
某一今天也是創高或一個明顯的壓迴
但是畢竟叫做創新高
那其實上個禮拜還有這個工業電腦的
研華創新高
然後還有所謂的這個
氣動元件大廠雅德克也創新高
雅德克
對所以機械人族群其實創高股票越來越多的話
對整個族群來講是一個加分的效果
那我們接下來看到所謂的一個
手機鏡頭箱
因為今天的光學鏡頭還蠻整齊的
我們講說其實今年的這個消費金電子
大家覺得好像沒有什麼樣看電
但我覺得上個禮拜
這個大陸的榮耀推出一個機器人手機
蠻特別的
特別在哪其實我們可以看一家影片
就是手機它會把這個鏡頭伸出來
變成一個機器人的一個
所謂多軸的一個雲台相機
然後它同時也可以跟你互動
是
對 所以這個我覺得代表說
其實手機到現在是求新求變了
那
可能大家就可以關注一下
這會不會有一些銷量的一個帶動
那當然大家重點還是在屬於蘋果
9月9號要發表iPhone 18 Pro Pro Max
跟摺疊手機
摺疊
大家可能最想知道摺疊帳怎樣
對 那今天其實新日新有動起來
雖然說還是非常溫
但是目前來看
我覺得就是這一次發表會之前
大家的關心是
蘋果供應鏈在發表會之前
容易來到高點
那發表會之後
又是這樣子的話
可能股價又拉回來了
所以我覺得目前來看
因為8月中
所以還有一段時間
大家可以去看一下蘋果供應的股票
其實我覺得有些都慢慢上來了
像你看到整體ky
像滑通這種多體財的
有蘋果加持
又有一些新體態帶動
深圳今天的光學競技股票也非常整齊
那主要原因在於說
因為 iPhoneSPA Pro
除了價格升級以外
鏡頭也升級了
好 它價格升級應該
記憶體佔了很大的因素
對 那我覺得多少
因為鏡頭也跟著升級了嘛
因為要賣比較貴
所以要讓大家有升級優感
那鏡頭賣比較貴
代表其實供應鏈的部分
應該也會有這種價格
應該單價提升
帶來毛率提升的一個效果
所以我們看到今天
台灣的兩個蘋果供應鏈
極放強
大力光你看今天已經來到五千塊了
再度重新往前高賣金
前高是六千多塊錢
繼續努力
對 因為之前這一段就是細光子
那現在細光子光通也開始轉強了
對 也轉強了
所以對他來講本益比提高了
那搭配蘋果忘記的來臨
我覺得就是所謂業績加持
搭配本盈比T高的效益
那目前股價已經來到5,070塊
我覺得其實大力光是有機會挑戰地址行高
是
因為現在台股市1萬多塊
我們講前股往6,000塊保持很久的記錄
看起來是他有機會重返榮耀
目前投信是連續
對 連續在買方
那外資跟他對做
但你會發現外資賣不下來
我們剛剛看到其實
8月份外資開始回補了
所以大家可以觀察一下
如果投信跟外資同買
那我覺得股價肯定有加速上昂的機會
那另外一檔 大一光上去大家想要預金光
預金光就長得跟他比較不一樣
走一個比較V轉 但位階比他低
對 因為大一光是先說他有光通
那預金光是我也有光通
但是大家對大一光覺得他量產的速度比較快
所以目前我覺得預金光他的優點在哪
他跟大一光有比較效應
而且有光通的一個題材
那目前也是要忘記來臨
我覺得他已經占到季線以上了
所以如果說你有的話就去報
如果沒有的話 你就回到季線附近
最近可以尋找一下支撐零買點
現在來看的話
其實它土壤是同步在買房
雖然都不是這樣的積極
但我覺得其實這個兩檔
光學性的股票
看起來現行跟價位都還不錯
那接下來大家會關心說
那台灣的船船股
今天貨櫃航運
萬海一馬當先的漲停版
大家說貨櫃航運又來了
然後剛好也進入到
所謂的貨櫃忘記了
那所謂的運價也有上揚
但是你這邊要教我們看的
還是要回到看一下來因何水位
我已經跟浩遠哥開玩笑說
如果沒漲
可能他乾掉了我們都不知道
對
那為什麼開始有這樣的一個題材出來
主要是來說
因為上個禮拜公布出來
萊英恆是重要的一個轉運的地方
這個地方是
河道相對比較平坦的
所以如果這個地方一旦開始斷航的話
整個萊英恆就出現了比較明顯的中斷
所以不用管河母在海峽
是美國的還是誰的
是不是
他們不是要收河母在海峽
對 那我覺得那個是地緣的風險
但我們講說如果連歐洲
所謂的傳統的合運都開始
所以塞過塞港
你相關歐洲港口開始塞的話
可能這個運價會加速上昂的情話
所以我們跟大家講
上個禮拜傳出來這個消息是8公分
那我今天早上再去查一下
這所謂多少
只剩下6公分
6公分
那真的快要沒有了
對 幾乎太陽塞一個下午
可能那個水就乾掉了
所以整體上來看的話
它代表說接下來
歐洲的所謂的供應鏈
物流運輸成本會上升
那對航運股有利
另外也可以留意到
對特化族群來講也有利
因為德國有非常多的化工大廠
他們的一個原物要斷掉的話
可能會停產
所以相關的
你看今天盤面上
中華化是拉高漲平板
我覺得有一點點
可能大家市場之間
慢慢在找這樣的一個題材
大家可以關注一下
但回到最直接相關就是
塞貴塞港誰社會
就貨櫃三小
好 所以我們來看
他今天盤面上的航運股
其實我覺得
首先還是看貨櫃
常常會讓人望海
對
因為他們最直接運家有表現
今天在大陸的歐縣騎火爆價
大家應該也很久沒有聽到這個名詞
很久沒去看了
以前就是以拜五或是每天那邊有相關網站的話
對 但今天是漲零半
所以你看今天為什麼萬海洋民能夠拉上來
我覺得跟爆價有關
那散裝的部分因為爆價還沒有上來
但剛剛提到
其實他們內閣行很多是透過散裝船去運送的
所以如果說那個運線斷掉的話
我覺得散裝爆價也有可能會轉強
所以代表說其實雖然電子股非常的迷人
但這種報價上漲的漲價概念
股在船航股裡面
我覺得大家也可以留意到
因為畢竟他們的業績也都非常好
那EPS上半年
其實像長榮是賺了一個股本以上
那萬海表現非常好
今年是出現年月雙生
還有這個計增的情況
陽明也是一樣
第一季雖然比較弱
但第二季開始成長了
所以我覺得
在相關的航運股
他們具備低本益比
而且有一些動能的優勢
所以我們來看這三檔股票
也大家很久沒有看了
但萬海變成大標股
好 萬海如果以這個形態看
一個創下今年的新高龍
對 今年新高
他有機會去挑戰兩年前的高點
兩年前就鴻海塞貴塞港的情況
那目前我覺得就型態來看
你看軍線是多頭的排列
那外資而且投信很
大戶很聰明
早就在卡位他了
所以代表業績
我覺得是可以
目前可以樂觀來期待
因為現在是歐美的航運旺季
那另外在長榮這樣股票
今天完成了田齊的動作
對 那股價前波高點242.5
換句話說 已經是過高了
所以我覺得他現在當然就是
這張股票這個萬海比較活潑
股信好
所以你可能就是順勢做動能
那長榮是一個價值型的投資
我覺得他比較穩健
所以這張股票我覺得都是這個
航運股當中可以留意到指標
目前這個長榮也是
外資連買投信開始在加碼的動作
投信這邊買很多
也許是被動勢的
但這一批都沒有賣掉
對 因為他是那時候搞股息
納入他 所以買了很多
那現在來看的話
因為今年應該也配不錯股息
所以持續有這個籌碼的轉強
那比較可憐是在陽明
不過他的獲利也確實三雄裡面最落後
對 因為我覺得也是在這幾年
他可能股本也比較大的關係
那我覺得目前陽明來看的話
你會發現到那兩股票都已經創高了
他還在相對低檔區
所以他就是落後補償的代表
那目前我覺得籌碼也慢慢轉強
所以如果說你覺得萬海太活潑
長榮太無聊的話
也許陽明是可以參考的補償的標的
但是以獲利來看
確實長榮是自由生
不管有沒有景氣循環
他都保持著這個高鼓勵
高獲利的一個狀態
你們非常謝謝浩偉哥
浩偉哥其實一口氣
講到了四種產業
機器人然後蘋果
還有記憶體幫大家回顧一下
還有貨櫃航運
真的不愧叫做題材獵人
那剛剛講到的
各個領域都有他的利機
或者是他有一些時間點的問題
像蘋果的新機
網紅會供應鏈
長在前面
這個我們要留意
但機器人是不是只長在
展覽前我們不妨觀察下去
因為他們的營運在今年
是有明顯的改善
而且各大廠也都紛紛的提出了合作案
接下來的佈局
各個新產品與數也要掛牌
他可能也走一個比較中波段的行情
提供給您做參考了
廣告回來 影響哥要上場
影響哥一直在關注
輝達的電力地圖
現在除了光寶科創高之外
他有擴散
包括大家很關注的向公立元件
甚至向碳化系相關的股票
等一下幫您塞一波
我們之前常常講到半導體有叫做三五足
除了這個碳化系
還有包括生化家林化英
像最近光通訊在講的
就是林化英缺料這件事情
如果講這些名詞
聽起來很生意
但是運用到實際的上面
他們都是很重要的
例如說剛剛講到的碳化系
或是像公路元件的
他就是在揮打的電力藍圖
裡面很重要
那林華英這個更不用講了
只要股價漲大
都會研究的什麼
連亞全新了
但這個族群還能看高做低嗎
對 這裡
Page買了
買了
對 上個禮拜五
就可以買這個禮拜三
上禮拜五買這禮拜三
對 所以現在這個
禮拜五的還沒買
所以我現在保命到禮拜三了
對 所以禮拜五的應該是
明天可能就可以
晚上就可以開始來佈局
可是現在很貴了吧
現在會比較貴啦
明天晚上以後可能會
對 比較有機會買便宜一點
是
目前來講我看起來是說
他可能走橫向的這個Wist點
比較機會大一點
所以你也是不打腳派的
對 原因是他的量呢
除非你要供到這個1.5兆
那才有機會打過這個所謂的前高
因為這Wist點剛好
我就大概1.5兆左右的一個量能
那我覺得說
現在來講也不求差量一定要馬上供出來
因為大家才剛調整
調整好心態
所以我覺得很走就是這個好
好事情
因為很走以後
慢慢的可能搞不好越線
又穿越過極限
對 那基本上就是說
這也來講
現在慢慢慢慢的一個收斂以後
其實這位置點我覺得還不錯
各股表現
應該還是有很多股票創立性性高
沒有錯
那今天大概
大家在談論的當然就是
回答這事情
好 800VDC的地圖
對 那因為800VDC呢
這個透過揮達這樣的事情
我覺得已經變成一個標準化
對 因為你可以發現說
目前來講他做的第一件事情說
二零二六年的下半年
他做的第一件事情是
原本很多機房早就建置好了對不對
所以原本是一個交流系統的
一個機房嘛
現在來講就是把這個東西就
等於是直接可以切入
原本的這個交流系統的一個機房
他跟很多家 Google Microsoft等等
大概聽說有八十個
那基本上 OCP 這個
也是共同開發這個架構
所以未來整個生態系來講
就是800 VDC 這個就會建構成
以後等於是直接進到這個
這個機房就直接是DC
對 等於是一個直流的一個環境
等於是說這個地圖
其實他涵蓋的零組件
真的非常的多
而且是一定要做的一件事情
那我們來看
就是我基本上
當然稍微列出來
你會發現
那比如說在這個
所謂的這個800
800服的這個高壓直流
對不對
這個概念來講
你會發現總體來講
那當然大家前面看到
就是台達電池跟光寶國
對 但是二哥比較厲害
對
那主要他基本上
當然是整個800服的這個
機櫃裡面
他整個模組化相關的決定方案
基本上這兩個等於是最大
那下面來講
當然就會有其他的
之前講的康書跟這個ASKY
那就是所謂的BBU
對 等於在這個所謂的
800V的這個電力裡面
下面會掛了一個BBU的一個系統
所以這一塊來講
也是屬於800V的這一塊
那最後來講就是說
這裡可能很多人
比較沒有去看到
就是你總要有很多零件
對 那現在零件來講
今天一直在講SI探話系
那湯花溪為什麼會提到湯花溪這個事情
就是說基本上因為湯花溪有耐高壓
對 耐高熱
那同時呢
他可以把他這個損耗降低
所以這樣的一個情況下來講
就是可以符合這個高壓直流裡面
那這個零件來講就相對重要
因為你還是要把它小化嘛對不對
縮小化
然後另外來講要耐高壓 耐高
所以這裡面來講
我們大概可以看
就是說所以開始來講
當然是大家會看所謂的這個龍頭這兩隻
雖然光寶可是創高
但它是溫和的
對 它比較共和
它也不是爆噴式的
所以施工剛剛有提到
還有機會再往上走
可是對他來講就是說
大家可以看就是說
基本上他跟那個
我們講說台達電的對應呢
對 台達電在兩千
兩千五百多這樣下來
兩千五百多下來的時候
他兩千五百多
他還在接近兩百的一個位置
那來講現在來講
他已經創高到兩百八十六
那台大店是回到這個2000以下
對 所以以這樣來看就是說
看高做低這個事情
我覺得是還是有利的
對 還是有利
也就是現在法人
你可能會 法人回去看一下
對 就是說 台大店
已經整理過來
然後在右下角再做整理的
那台大店來講
現在剛好在右下角整理
我覺得台大店基本上
還是有機會了
那他基本上
對他講也是有機會
因為他第二季的收益真的非常好
剛好看到大概
第二季當然三塊多嘛
對不對 三塊一
那比第一季來講
等於是這個成長是倍數的一個成長
那康初來講
我覺得說他基本上
剛好第二季發出來的財報
比較差一點
對 因為之前有提到
我們今天剛好也幫大家
再做一下追蹤對不對
他就變成一個
在一個虛間小整理
一直不上不下
那因為他本來在這一塊裡面
BPU裡面也是佔了一個很重要
在800VDC這一塊
而且會加位低
那最重要的是他第二季
可能有一些開銷
開一下費用
費用減掉以後
變成說他第二季的
這一批是降下來
可是他營收是上來的
是沒有問題的
對
所以這一塊
我覺得說大家可能要等待
這一塊來講就是說長遠看
他的下半年大家還是看好了
對
因為今年還是大概
法人是供他接近到
到這個快三塊左右
所以看起來
他下半年
如果是能夠一季
大概達到一塊錢左右
那基本上是有可能是往上購買
等放量對不對
這兩天量也急縮
因為至少還站在月線之上
我覺得還好
好 幫大家追蹤
強茂 公立元件也是大家關注的
那基本上剛剛有看到兩個部分
就是在這個燙花系裡面
那基本上強茂做的是所謂的這個元件
比如說他是做這個所謂的燙花系
就是二級體的一部分
所以這個元件基本上
在這裡面 公立元件裡面
他前面有一個題材
就是漲價題材
他跟被動
你就被動跟主動
都是一座山
他漲價題材起來以後
連續噴了三根漲停
對 整理過後又攻
那這一塊來講
基本上這漲價是確立的
是 所以以他來講
就是說為什麼我特別畫這個圖
就是說其實在這樣的一個位置點來講
我們之前有講過
當他越過前高開始攻的時候
那基本上就是一個
我所謂的一個支撐
那另外來講
這是一個另外的一個漲價的起漲點
那現在來講
剛好又回到漲價的一個起漲點
對呀 真的就回到原點
那對於高點來講
這個落差還很大
所以我倒覺得說
以這個點
剛好他也落在所謂的一個
一個月線之上
那我倒覺得說
有發亮攻擊的時候
基本上他還是有機會做一個
所謂的一個拉伸的一個動作
而且他這邊其實殺下來的時候
這邊都沒有亮對不對
對
所以他要往上克服應該是
還需要打一點亮起來
因為這裡面基本上這個亮是
亮在這裡
有大概五萬張
在這個地方
到這邊會有壓力
對 所以如果有一點亮拉伸的話
他基本上還是有機會
是 公眾員進也是很多散戶朋友套在裡面
那基本上我特別講一下
就是說嘉金這一種
嘉金 可能很多人也沒有注意到
因為嘉金這一支來講
他是做碳化系裡面的
等於是比較上游
有一點類似什麼
類似我們講零化硬
是看這個三年八一的這個連亞
連亞 對
那他是做累晶的一個部分
對他來講
他已經開始怎麼樣
收益不錯
從這個毛利七點九趴
到2026年Q2已經達到23.5%
所以他的這個
去年虧錢的情況下
今年第二季已經達到0.65%
轉虧為營了
對 轉虧為營
就是大概已經比第一季
大概多了89%的這個
這個繼成長
那以這樣來講就是說
確實在這一塊裡面
我覺得說
如果貪花系這個需求會起來
那最源頭基本上這個
這個累積部分
我覺得他是有機會
那因為年增確實是不錯的
那另外還有一個
也就是說他其實不只是碳化系這一塊
是 對 他基本上在這裡
有一個所謂的西光紙的一個引擎
所以他認為說在二零二六年
下半年以後 開到二零二七年會發動
因為這塊來講就是說
確實啦 在這一塊
他等於是在在光通訊的
這一塊裡面的這個基礎
這是什麼 這是 者細跟什麼
這比較難念 者細跟
所謂的一個累晶的部分
所以這一塊來講
那我覺得說這一塊是有機會的
所以以這樣的一個成長動能來講
就是說基本上今年
大概有看到大概三塊錢左右
我們看一下
之前大概看到三塊錢
明年可能預估
反正估得很好 估到接近八塊
不過像這種貪花系列的
他們的獲利波動真的很大
獲利波動很大
那我覺得說他也是一樣
就是說前面這個也都是因為
這個這個細光的一個部分
那產生的一個基金源的部分拉動起來
那我覺得說現在拉回來修正過後也是一樣
就是說當他的錢高回來變成一個支撐以後
那現在打上去站在月線之上
我覺得說這個都還有機會再供上去的一個機會
之前的謝金源大概講說
怎麼都是這個環球金和金
怎麼不講一下家金
他也有他的功能
所以今天也有來幫大家聊到
未接確實是裡面比較好
沒錯 因為看2027年基本上
如果估了這麼好 當然是有機會
希望能達到啦
因為這個族群以前
就是破例破弄超級大
那現在我們也看了一下
這個這個林華英
很紅喔
也是今天的一個重點
那因為林華英裡面的代表座
林雅 林雅跟全型
林雅又快要創高
又快要創高
就很恐怖了
因為你會發現
那確實啦
還是他的七月營收來講
也是創高的
也是厲害的
對 那歪歪來講是
是176%
對 那雖然說他的收益來講
感覺是剛在起步啦
那因為今年來講
孤子大概在二十塊
可是我們想說明年孤子是翻倍
所以為什麼他會拉到這種千元
就是說大家看他為了來持長性
因為他也是等於是這個
零化硬的源頭
對 源頭
所以基本上這一次來講
可能大家會看說
這個聯亞的部分
那另外來講就是這三支
就是等於是以前這樣
PA三雄
我沒有群星紅結科
對 那其實紅結科呢
比較少人去提到
其實他也有切入這一塊
上個禮拜一有一個人提到
他現在在後面
對 就是施工
那因為你看 他的收也不錯
他上倍也將近大概三塊錢
是
對 因為才120塊
他是最便宜的
因為這裡面來講
全新營在400塊
文貿已經400塊
沒錯
對 那120塊來講
他現在的本益比就只有21倍
因為你要接近他所謂的一個
我們講說這個細光的部分
那基本上這個
本益率都非常高
那到明年來講
如果估到六塊多
他等於是只有到二十倍左右
那我們來看一下
做什麼事情
因為我先看一下聯亞
快要創高的聯亞
所以我覺得說他有機會
我覺得明天就有機會
拉到這個高點的位置
前面還有一個高
因為我覺得三千多塊
對 沒錯
三千多塊
那全新的部分來講
就是說確實
這來講也是一樣
也是差一點點
就要拉上位點
今天都非常強勢
就開盤沒都已經鎖掌平了
那所以說今天如果整個看起來
紅結刻這一間
為什麼會特別談到紅結刻
因為剛剛有提到
以前大家都認為他是在PA的部分
對啊手機
他真正在切絡的部分
光束包模組已經有出來了
所以光束包這VC有這一塊
基本上是他已經開始有
這個啟動他的一個布局
那最重要是剛講PD
PD我們講說這個所謂的
光偵測的一個部分
這個就是所謂的
我們講說在這裡需要所謂的
零化因對不對
如果你現在來講
就是說現在本來靠這個PA的一個部分
他就可以賺到二零二六
接近五塊錢
那明年的話
估值大概是到六塊多
到二零二八年他八塊多
這個可能就是因為這個所謂的一個
這個這個GPU的部分
產生的這個收益出來
所以我覺得說以這一塊來講
他是蠻有機會的
那以現土來講
就是說確實這一波來講
本來他是非常漂亮
對 一直言得上升對盜
那在這裡就是說七月份
就是剛好破了這個所謂的
上升軌道的一個下遠
確實來講 對他來講
就是一個不要偏空的一個部分
可是現在重新又站回月線
我就是說以他現在來講說
站回月線之後
這個所謂的上升軌道的下遠
會變成他的壓力點
對 不過這壓力點
離這個120左右的位置點
非常遠
大概還有百分之
接近三成的一個位置
所以我倒覺得說
以這一塊來講的時候
他一樣有量能攻擊的時候
基本上你不要忘了說
他跟這個靈化鷹的這一塊的一個相關性很強
所以我覺得說還是非常有機會
所以等於雲祥哥會從題材面對不對
同族群已經有人在創高了
可是他位置卻很低
但是也要有條件的齊劇
例如說他要有量能放出來
所以我們可以先把它放進觀察名單
或是宣布一點局
等到量放到再來作家
沒錯 這邊非常謝謝雲祥哥
剛剛好像又進入到了化學課一樣
不過這些三五族確實可以
應用在各領域在AI上面
也是不可或缺的關鍵原料
像剛剛講到的家晶
它有碳化系相關的
不管是電力 吸金元等等的運用
其他的佈局範圍是非常廣
重點在轉虧文藝
現在法人對他明年的期待
是非常高的
至於林華英不用講了
因為股價已經表態了
那同族群裡面有股價表態的
自然也有相對比較落後的
就等他的發動量跟市場認同
我們都是可以先來做鎖骨觀察的
今天非常謝謝三外的朋友來到現場
台股大戰從上個禮拜五
在四萬六附近就有點盡觀情趣
但是可以看到在各族群
有領頭羊表態的情況下
AI的這股熱潮
其實默默的是在內部發光發熱的
也代表台股在往新高
邁進的路上是不會急摸的
那也希望今天理財大戰秀
對於投資有幫助喔
明天再會了 拜拜
字幕by索兰娅